GUIPEUN KANG: So octopuses use its arm to explore.
COREY ALLARD: And people have
wondered about this for a while,
how they are using those arms to do this -
how they're finding things on the seafloor.
VOICEOVER: Octopuses feel their
way to a tasty meal but for a
long time researchers have believed
there is more than touch going on.
COREY ALLARD: Touch-taste senses is
the term that combines elements of
mechanical sensitivity and
also chemical sensitivity.
VOICEOVER: Now researchers
think they're uncovering the
molecular mechanism behind this
proposed 'chemotactile' sense.
COREY ALLARD: How does this apparent
chemotactile sense work? What are the
cells? What are the molecules? And how does
the animal use them to interact with its world?
VOICEOVER: And their work is opening a new window
into how sensory systems evolve and
how those systems impact behaviour.
GUIPEUN KANG: Octopuses are excellent
model systems to understand how molecular
evolution affects the sensory systems of animals.
VOICEOVER: Octopuses experience the
world very differently from humans.
COREY ALLARD: Certainly there are
some things that are familiar,
we know that octopus are visual
animals and they'll use their eyes, but
what's really striking about them is the way they
use those sort of enigmatic eight arms that they
have - and they're using those to really reach
into cracks in the sea floor to probe around to
surfaces or areas that aren't accessible to things
like their eyes that maybe they can't see into.
VOICEOVER: Octopuses appear to be able to accept
or reject potential prey using only their arms
and it was this behaviour that led researchers
to investigate their sensory capabilities.
COREY ALLARD: There were some very early studies
from the 1960s that showed what looked like
sensory cells in the epithelium of the sucker
cups and that was one of the things that got
us curious in the first place that - yeah it
seems like maybe there's a bona fide sensory
system housed within the arms and the sucker cups,
but we don't know anything about how it works.
VOICEOVER: But the publication of the first
octopus genome in 2015 has led to new studies
including research into gene expression
profiles in different parts of the octopus.
COREY ALLARD: The rationale here is that the
sensory receptors we're looking for should be
more abundant in the rims of the sucker
cups versus other places in the octopus.
And what was really striking to us was
that instead of a single receptor or a
couple receptors we identified an entire
family of these chemotactile receptors.
VOICEOVER: But the receptors they identified
which they call chemotactile reception or CRs
didn't look like the kind of receptors
usually seen in sensory systems.
COREY ALLARD: They didn't resemble known sensory
receptors instead they're most closely related to
a family of receptors called
nicotinic acetylcholine receptors.
VOICEOVER: Nicotinic acetylcholine
receptors are found throughout the
nervous system of many different animals but
usually they detect neurotransmitters within
the body and are involved with things
like controlling muscle contractions.
In humans that a focus of research into
treatments for everything from Parkinson's
disease to nicotine addiction but they are not
sensory receptors or so researchers thought.
COREY ALLARD: In the course of their
evolution octopus have converted these
ancestral nicotinic acetylcholine receptors
into sensory receptors they look almost
identical at first glance and it wasn't until
we looked closer that we started to appreciate
some of the structural regions that are
mediating these functional differences
VOICEOVER: The team imaged the octopus receptors
using cryo-electron microscopy and compared to
structure they found with the nicotinic receptors
found commonly in other animals and they found a
subtle but very important difference in an area
called the ligand binding site. This is where
the receptor binds with its chemical partner.
In nicotinic receptors this is a cage-like
structure that binds with neurotransmitters
like acetylcholine causing its ion channel to
open and transmit signals, but the octopus
receptors are different. Instead of a cage
they've evolved to have a shallow groove and
that allows for a wider range of materials to
bind in particular materials that don't
mix well with water like the kinds of
greasy residues left on the sea floor by
potential prey, a useful tool in a hunt.
COREY ALLARD: We describe this as being a
chemo tactile sense which basically combines
chemo sensation sensation of chemicals
who have tactile sensation or touch.
VOICEOVER: This clarified picture of
the molecular mechanism behind taste
by touch helps explain some of the octopus's
unique behaviours - especially when compared
to the structures of the same types of
receptor in related animals like squid.
GUIPEUN KANG: Octopuses use their chemotactile
receptors for their exploratory predation
behaviour. Interestingly octopus and
squid have a different predatory strategy,
instead of using its arms for exploration,
rather squid - ambush predator - hides,
strike and pull their potential prey
and then decide to eat or reject it.
VOICEOVER: This behavioural difference, the
researchers say, can be explained by their
different receptors. For example the octopus
receptors wouldn't work in the open water.
COREY ALLARD: The types of chemicals that
they're actually able to sense are very
hydrophobic molecules things that you would
not expect to find in the water column in a
marine environment and things that instead
you would expect to find on the surfaces in
a marine environment, so it makes sense that
they would have to physically touch them.
GUIPEUN KANG: On the contrary
the squid chemotactile receptor
binding site, is not responding to
greasy molecules. Instead it responds to a
bitter tastents, that are soluble and easily
diffusive in water. It explains squid's
strikingly different predatory behaviour.
VOICEOVER: Evolutionary differences at
a molecular level align with strikingly
different abilities and behaviours. And
this is far from the end of the story
GUIPEUN KANGE: Oh yeah, there are there
are a lot of things we don't understand,
here we just started look at one
of each receptor from octopus and
squid there are more octopus and
squid chemotactile receptors with
different properties [they] may pursue
different functions in sensory system.
VOICEOVER: For example, there is evidence
that some octopus receptors can also detect
voltage but how this ability fits into their
broader sensory system is still unknown even
within the world of the chemotactile receptors
already studied there's much more to learn.
COREY ALLARD: You know we initially got
into this study thinking that we would
be studying a sensory system that's
used for predation for finding prey
and while we still think that's the case so
far most of what we've discovered relates to
perversive stimuli or things that the octopus
doesn't like and so we're really interested
to find if somewhere in this diversity of CRs
there are receptors that mediate what we would
call appetitive sensation or, you know, food
- things that the octopus maybe wants to eat.
Or if the octopus maybe just eats anything unless
it has a signal that says no don't eat this.
VOICEOVER: Researchers are gradually
building a better comprehension of
how sensory systems evolve and being able to
combine behavioural observation with complex
structural understanding give scientists yet
another piece in the evolutionary puzzle.
GUIPEUN KANG: Cephalopods, including nautilus
and cuttlefish - they're evolving differently
from octopus and squids, so that would
be very interesting to see how and why
they're different from a molecular,
atomic level to animal behaviour level.